welcome to the splits game against EMG
sharaf checker off from Argentina I've
played him three times i won three times
every serious was about to come to an
end at some point but maybe not yet okay
he played the two nights variation and
this is an interesting sideline against
that Knight f6 champion by German Grand
Master you are drinking Yvonne kinking
I'm not sure about the pronunciation
really ok I've reached a fairly typical
Carol composition the bishop outside of
the pawn chain which is nice and maybe
have some plans to pressurize the e5
pawn and down and then I probably needs
to play deform at some point and more
interesting ok I need to take probably
and what now all night c16 looks very
logical the f5 long i really want to
prevent their five yeah this looks like
a very
a very sound position for black so don't
have any particular weaknesses should i
do that not clear how why not I don't
have any particular weaknesses
interesting movie form if i take he gets
hmm that's it's a good move Mary he gets
a four for a snide very interesting okay
I at least want to have c4 as a possible
point of attack and gathers means i
should have played differently maybe h6
first also not clear okay at least he
does not have a pawn break on the
queenside and I I should still be fairly
solid to him this night however I need
to do something about hmm how do I am
regroup my pieces here that it's always
on f7 not not nice show page six no miss
blunders blunder cm
hmm maybe rookies I don't know check I
need to get rid of this this piece
really okay now i can give this check
but i think i have to shop f8 later and
that yang did he needs to you need to
retreat again the good thing about my
position is that may be the only thing
is that this night only three is not
really playing okay if I exchange now
and queen d8 my jack
the more pieces come off the the better
my position gets as the weakness on c4
gets more important 96 no ok so I better
cover that they have Knight a5 maybe
soon to attack the weakness should I
play a six to expel the night night if I
don't really get get to attack a form oh
wait I can do this and I play a 69 a
three and then create form yeah this is
in fact really i can play Bishop see one
but Queen D 1 okay this is good for
black well really hey I don't mind he
does not have a 50 or any dramatic move
I need to I need to keep the position
closed of course if I cannot maybe just
this one how does he protects your phone
Oh like this okay okay but the night is
not the bishop is not easily activated
this is important here here ok but I can
take here it's a check should i do that
it activates a special better better not
if you place bishop f6 I can take any
way maybe now and then go into a form
few chicks check I have this Queenie
phones and it's not so clear where you
should go now yet f 10 I know Queen d7
oh this is a shame I forgot about that
one yeah that's then then this was a
very unsuccessful operation really 95
maybe I have Quinn g5 naija form if he
goes on the e-file and other than that I
take it oops while I'm overlooking far
too many things in this game heck no
come on I really don't want to do this
game this is would be a shame really
it's not threatening anything I morning
yeah yeah yeah I know Christ check how
unnecessary is that yeah if I was
completely moronic how could you play e5
check draw Alfred
now of course just a piece Oh God yeah
this was really really a shame come on
black reason 5 was so idiotic this is
really completely enter positional move
completely ah yes check yeah 27 I forgot
that he has 27 immediately and this
really is counterplay I mean okay the
comp probably wins this easily but human
not so easy and it's completely
unnecessary this is so good no words I
mean I Casey can even just bring the
king over or whatever I control the
default yes no entry square it's just
completely dead this position if five is
really a double ? album again before
that I really didn't understand anything
I mean 96 is completely unnecessary he
can think and go here I mean it is it is
a bad position but it was a bad position
basically for for a long while so I
noticed I'm not sure why you would give
up another pawn and this is probably
even better good winning it like this
yeah but if I if wow this was really bad
really really bad I have all the time in
the world here edius is probably to get
the king over first and then only then
think about opening the position I
control the D file a control f5 this
means he has absolutely no counter play
and I played d5 to open useless position
out for as be sure this is just they
really should strip me of my rating now
and now this is already very tricky at
least an in blitz chess the comp is on
minus one point something
but it's not easy to play I need to play
a defensive move and then I can try to
coordinate again but it was entirely
unnecessary why give him this this type
of counter play ah ok thanks for
watching